i try to get guys that's not on my level  a chance why what do you mean on your  level that's making six figures or more  because i want i honestly wanna a sixth  speaker guy um is what i'm realizing  okay so let me just go ahead and net it  out for you the guys you want aren't  asking you out why why do you think that  is that  women tend to do that cause we were  talking about that yesterday how  women will go for typically the bum  except and  except for to go for the bum and not go  for someone that is more on their level  okay there's three reasons okay i've  laid out one  bombs have a lot of free time  so we usually got a game  as true um two okay i think there's some  girls that like dominating a  relationship and they like feeling  competent and so they like being with  someone less than them so they can like  shine  and i think looks like they can't  because men and women are valued for  different things so guys don't care how  much money you make